foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios this is the Ramsay show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money I am
Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz hosting
today with best-selling author and
Ramsey personality Ken Coleman so we are
taking your calls this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
give us a call it's free anywhere in the
country at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
so can
yes I don't know I just feel like I feel
like things are fascinating right now in
the world oh that's a very uh very mild
way of putting that yes it's a very
positive way of putting that yes it's uh
we have a lot of confusing economic data
we've got political stuff going on it's
a very interesting year to say the least
I would say a watershed year I believe
that I think when we look back you could
probably say that about the last two
years but I think this year you know
with it being a political year where
you're going to have midterm elections
which which mean a lot and and and then
you look at how the economy is doing you
know it's we're seeing a high high job
opportunities we're seeing increased pay
pays at an all-time high but inflation
is at an all-time high okay and then you
got the interest rates going up but yet
we're not in a full-blown recession
there's just a lot happening right now
in the next six to 12 months I think are
going to be even more fascinating to use
your word yes for sure so I mean
obviously the Fed raised the rate
recently I mean this this whole thing
the inflation everything people are
feeling yeah and specifically on you
know their budget side the expenses
right you're still feeling gas even
though it's gotten a little bit better
but groceries are still at an all-time
high I mean everything food at any time
I buy anything whether we're like
booking a hotel room or or I mean just
everything don't forget utilities we see
electric electric is going up a lot of
economists are saying in Industry uh
insiders are saying that electric bills
are going to go even higher so now we're
coming into obviously a season where
you're gonna have your heating bills go
up so it's not just food and uh some of
your clothing and Retail expenses it's
as those utilities are going up as well
to the point that for people who have
gotten nice pay raises the pay raises
haven't outpaced inflation okay that's
what I want to talk to you about because
that's hard yeah for sure well and
people are feeling this I mean very much
and even us I'm like we I was just doing
our budget for October and I was like
I'm having to like to bump up because we
just keep going like on groceries on
this stuff like I'm like we're just
feeling it so talk to me about wages
though because I see statistics that
wages are going up but some people are
saying no I'm not feeling that at all
right so what are you saying well wages
are definitely up that's just
historically we're seeing
um hourly wage earners are making way
more money people that have changed jobs
in the great resignation which just a
quick snapshot on that that's about 60
million people have changed jobs since
the middle of 2021. it's extraordinary
the 21 not even coven which was a whole
other it's not even count covered so
what we're seeing is yes incomes are
going up but if you don't have the
discipline to use the Ramsey Way right
to budget and know where your money's
going well you can get a nice bump but
number one it feels good that always
feels good you see a bigger paycheck but
if you're not in the details of a budget
you don't necessarily see immediately
the cost of growth groceries if you're
not paying attention to your grocery
budget and you're just going on buying
all the same items that I buy before but
if and then I look at it after I pay and
I go wait a second the same exact thing
that I paid for six months ago is now
100 to 200 more yep well that starts to
creep up we did see gas prices go up so
to your point money's not going as far
as people think it's going yeah and then
they wake up and go wait a second
something's not right I got a 15 pay
bump
but I'm still having problems with not
meeting all my monthly needs they're
eating out by the way let's not talk I
mean let's just just let this be focused
on groceries what about eating out yeah
the other day and I'm infamous for not
paying attention to the bill like Stacy
gives me a hard time about it I just
don't pay attention to the bill you just
say you just keep going I look at the
total and I pay attention to the tip
yeah she's a line item looker oh
I go right to the bottom and I go what
do I owe my waiter yeah that's all I
care about yeah because I've already
pre-selected mine what you want to eat
yeah but here's the deal if you don't
pay attention to that it's like what
used to be a little family outing oh
yeah of 50 bucks is now 75 yes 80. yes
so all of these things is the real
impact of inflation we we hear
economists and newsmakers talk about
well this category in this category this
category but here it ends up going
across the board so it bottom line is
life is more expensive right now and to
where people are a little bit depressed
they changed for a job to get a better
paycheck and they're going
it didn't keep up with it so what am I
going to do ask for another raise I
can't ask for a raise can I've only been
on the job three months the answer is
you give yourself a raise by using the
financial principles we teach on the
show yeah and being so diligent and more
than ever it's this whole conversation
too of
of needs versus wants and what's what's
hard is what what is a want has become a
need right like because you're just used
to it you're used to having X Y and Z
fill in the blank whether it's a
subscription or whatever it may be and
it's like yeah we can't live without
that yeah we can't live without Hulu we
can't live without Disney plus what does
Hulu cost do you even know I don't even
know we have Netflix and Amazon Prime
probably like 10 bucks yeah 9.99 what is
it I think it's like six bucks there's
all these different tiers now the one we
did is six but then you here's the deal
so I'll call ourselves out you look up
one day and you go oh that's right I
forget Stacy signed us up for Disney
Plus
and we got Netflix and we got Amazon
Prime because I'm we buy everything from
Amazon sadly 100 so do we and then you
go oh I got apple plus yeah and then I
see this really cool commercial for a
show that I gotta see on Hulu and then
on Showtime and then yeah Paramount plus
because I gotta watch Yellowstone oh
yeah you gotta have them all and to your
point man big Tech thing yeah now you
got what 100 bucks and subscription
services
and you know what source for me here's
where I'm not diligent and I really I
really should just like figure this out
apple apple takes my money I have like a
299 here a four night and I'm like I
think I've bought the cloud somewhere or
the cloud but yet I have Dropbox like
I'm like I have all this stuff that I'm
like oh yeah I'm duplicating probably
the same thing oh my gosh and I'm like
oh it's just you know 4.99 here and over
time you're like oh get you guys okay
we we need to be diligent here's my
confession I'm the worst at this my poor
wife y'all pray for her I'll sign up for
something some sports app that I got
like I'm traveling and I could only
watch the game on this one app or
something like that yeah and it's the
automatic renewal because I say to
myself oh it's free for 30 days and I'll
remember to cancel it here's the deal I
never remember and she's like what is
this charge I know CBS Sports Plus what
is that well as I had to listen to the
Michigan game yeah it's that's I'm the
worst at that at the old age trick me
because I always forget to unsubscribe
or whatever you know what's sneaky to me
is you buy something this has happened
to me twice Ken in the last five months
and I'm like is this the new
a hair thing a hair product thing and a
makeup thing separate companies
and they have shipped me the same
products four months later and charged
me again I was like whoa I didn't sign
up for a subscription I didn't sign up
for that oh but you did sneaky she had
no idea subscribe watching your expenses
people is gonna help so much and even
the 15 20 bucks that saves gives you
margin this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting today with Ken
Coleman and we are taking your calls on
life money career relationships anything
and everything we are here to have a
conversation with you so give us a call
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five all right up next we have Micah
in Cincinnati hey Micah welcome to the
show
hi Rachel hi Ken how are you guys we're
doing great how can we help
awesome well so I have this really kind
of random opportunity for a job and it
was one that HR basically said I didn't
have an opportunity to have so I thought
well I'll just go ahead and apply and
get my name up there anyways and just so
they can kind of get a name to a face in
case it opens up again and the two
people above me in seniority that
applied
um did not get the job so I got a phone
call and they said okay 330 come in
you've got an interview so it's like
crap what do I do so
um just a quick background is the job I
have now absolutely love it and
it's it's one of those where it's almost
it's so easy that you just feel like you
don't ever want to leave but I also am
just kind of struggling with job
satisfaction I guess because
um as a I'm an aircraft mechanic and I
build I build jet engines and basically
this this new job will offer me more
opportunities to develop as a mechanic
and I'm only 27. so I would love to
retire doing what I'm doing it's just
I feel like 37 years to retirement doing
the same thing over and over is probably
not going to work out great so I just
I'm kind of puzzled because it was such
a fast opportunity
um so yeah and it's today you might hear
the interview
yeah it's like literally in an hour so
what's okay so why'd you call us what's
on your mind
um I guess I'm trying to outweigh like
does
does the little raise and the
opportunity to advance myself in my
career does that should that outweigh
the security and the ease of the current
job that yeah so it's basically yes yes
yes for the reasons that you just gave
it you gave to the audience it was very
eloquent by the way I mean you just laid
it out look I got a really good job I
like it I'm good at it but I don't have
any satisfaction and what you didn't say
is that you're bored and I think that's
what's really going on and there's no
way you can do this for 37 more years
those are your words not mine and so yes
you were in a comfort zone right now but
all growth happens outside of the
comfort zone and what will happen is if
you were to not pursue this whether you
get it or not but if you were not to
pursue this or pursue something else and
continue to climb the ladder when we
stay in this place of comfort
then we find that complacency and misery
are not very far behind complacency
leads to misery
and yet as people Rachel we we prefer
we'd rather be miserable than
uncomfortable because change is so scary
change is just it's just it puts us in a
place of of being uncomfortable so I
would say young man yes at least go
listen
at least go listen I mean does it hurt
for you to show up you were interested
in it before
enough to kick the tires
I'm not sure why I even applied but
that's just from leaving my last child
to coming here I was like oh man I did
it and then God just opened these doors
I wasn't supposed to get in this job in
the first place and there's company in
the first place because I don't have the
experience and here it's like it feels
like God's just opening these doors and
I'm like crap I mean maybe maybe maybe
God's opening the doors because you're
sharing with them your heart maybe he
knows your heart he knows you're bored
you I don't believe you that you say you
don't know why
I think you know why and it's just a
gamble too okay because I'm curious the
two people you said that were even above
you didn't get it so I'm curious like
what the what the qualifications are
what they're looking for the credentials
all of that so let's just say Micah you
go and you don't get it but this is
still stretching you like there's still
that that opportunity for growth even if
there is a rejection on the other end
that's a great Point uh you're you're
still doing something you have movement
and what Ken was saying too being
stagnant for a while I guess could be
comfortable in the crazy world where you
live that you're just like you know what
it's predictable and it's and we're here
and I know what I'm doing but that only
will take you so far and and the boredom
will catch up Micah so I think that
that's a it's a great question and I
appreciate you calling right before your
interview so yeah fun stuff kill it and
I hope yeah you walk right through that
door that's been open to you and yeah
last thing I'd say on this is no
pressure today ask every question you
want to ask like allow yourself to be so
engaged in this interview that you allow
your brain to get out of the way in your
heart to talk
your heart will tell you uh whether or
not you want to do this but it is always
good to listen it's good all right up
next we have Julie in Phoenix hey Julie
welcome to the show
Julie hello Hi how are you Hi how are
you we're doing well
yeah yeah
for sure uh basically I have I'm not
sure so much it's Financial family uh it
got to the point that I literally had to
stop speaking to my mother and I'm
guessing it's has to do with finances
and I just wanted to get your advice
um I I got saved at the age of 21 I was
in debt over ten thousand dollars I put
myself in bootstraps I paid it off in
one year wow and
um after that I just kind of stayed
living in New York my mother accumulated
that from about 10 to 12 000.
um they started chewing her dragging her
to court I felt I needed to do something
because she was not doing anything and
she turned to me and I paid about four
thousand dollars to file for bankruptcy
for her
and
um there was about seven eight years I'm
30 now so that was seven eight years ago
and I paid and that was all of my money
and I made her promise and promise and
promise that she will never get a credit
card again because after I paid off all
of my credit cards and debts I caught
everything I've never used the credit
card any debt again basically and you
found that you can't change people
yes and within a year or two she had
multiple credit cards again she tried to
kind of hide it from me that they were
coming in the mail sure and then maybe
five years she was right back where she
was 10 to maybe twelve thousand dollars
and they started to try to track her to
court again yeah she turned to me
basically like are you gonna take care
of it like I I didn't know what to do I
called the attorney her bankruptcy
attorney and she was like what's wrong
with your mother you can file bankruptcy
every four to three years or five years
you can only do it every 10 years
a long story short I moved to uh to
another state to be in full-time
Ministry then covert hit she moved uh to
the state with me and then after some
time it's just she was making very not
smart financial decisions
and it was just I'm starting to feel the
point I was getting suffocated
and I when I moved when I was done with
the ministry and I moved to another
state now I'm in Arizona I
um she always wants to move in with me
so basically you know I can like pay at
least half of the bills yeah so Julie we
have a heartbreak coming up hey Julie we
have a heartbreak coming up what what
what's gave me the situation today and
how Ken and I can kind of walk you
through and give you our thoughts uh she
keeps asking me for money
um I keep trying to move in with me okay
and I I I can yeah when I was 19 she was
encouraging me to take out a student
loan to pay attention hey Julie Julie
um listen this is a hard no you've gotta
you gotta put up some boundaries Rachel
she's gotta put some boundaries up with
Mom and it's a tough situation because
it's her mother yeah yeah it is for the
last two years and she would emotionally
like blackmail me she would guilt-trip
me it got to the point where she would
call and I would like
my blood pressure would go up yeah yeah
listen listen stop speaking to her Julie
listen I I I understand this is so
wildly painful and so hard
but the fact is you're you're already in
pain she's already putting you in this
situation
and so it's not going to get any worse
if you literally say no and you put the
boundaries it's not going to get any
worse than it already is
but by keeping by giving her continued
power
to manipulate you and I'm being very
specific with that word your mother is
manipulating you and you do love her and
is because you love her that she has the
power to manipulate you but we can hear
the pain in your voice Rachel I mean
around it's well it is and Julie having
putting up those boundaries is really
difficult and I think being very clear
with her
and saying Mom I'm not giving you any
more money and if that is the string
that keeps us together then Julie
there's a point in which is the most
heartbreaking thing when a family is
destroyed but she's destroyed like I
hear it in your voice Julie that you
can't handle this anymore and so there's
going to be a really hard boundary that
you that you had say that I just we
can't have a relationship if this is how
you're gonna treat me and this is for
the good of you Julie for the good of
you in your life and that's a hard
boundary but it's a loving one for you
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show well
it's no secrets that we love talking
about money and we know not everyone
feels that way but that's one reason
George Campbell and I started a new
podcast that we wanted to bring the fun
back to money we wanted to make a casual
conversational podcast around things
that are going on in the world today and
in regards to money so last week we
launched a brand new Ramsay podcast
called smart money happy hour where
again George and I we kind of dig into
the stuff that your friends would talk
about at a weekly happy hour you know
pop culture what's going on in the world
uh how you can afford to live a life you
love and obviously so you slip out the
money stuff into normal conversation
into the normal conversations yeah we're
just like okay so what's going on in the
world give people an example of First
episodes go on Bingo Bongo it's amazing
congratulations thank you let's give
them a bite first of all wait a second I
have ADC I want to check this James make
sure this is we had no happy hour
happening here okay that's water it's
water I can attest that is right that is
water I didn't know you know you do
smart money happy hour George where you
have an adult beverage I was wondering
if it was going to creep into the Big
Show and I can now tell everybody rest
assured and there's water in here as
well folks all right oh people want to
know they they're curious I'm sure they
are I'm sure they are uh so give me an
example of first episode a pop culture
thing and then you kind of pivot into
them yeah so first yeah we talked about
the things that are keeping you broke
and so we walk through the first episode
about nine different things everything
from Amazon Prime to the free shipping
things will get you on websites so yeah
we kind of walk you through all that we
talk about uh the second episode is
about your house HGTV and how it ruins
our generation I know man tough time
that almost got me in some trouble I
wanted to buy every Fixer-Upper I would
drive by because I love chip so much
yeah and you're like chip and Joanna I
could take a sledgehammer to that wall
Stacey's like you can barely hold a hand
you can barely slow your roll
so yeah if you want to listen you guys
make sure that's great subscribe to
Smart money happy hour and it's living
in the top 20 of all podcasts it's been
there uh for now like five six days
which is awesome so so we have new
episodes every Thursday that launch the
Royals might be one topic launching soon
uh Disney
the whole Disney conversation from
Disney World Disney adults all of that
yeah we just have some fun stuff some
reality TV episodes coming out so
anyways we're really excited about it
and we have a lot of fun so we hope that
this will be a great podcast that you
guys will enjoy and if you have a friend
or a family member that they maybe the
Ramsey show is a little too hardcore or
something for them this is a nice little
it's a lighter Fair yeah a little
lighter and I think you've got to point
out that that you that there that you
guys have one beverage and uh do you
review the beverage we do so yes so
every episode we have a different drink
there may be a mocktail we had a
mocktail in one episode too so we're
mixing it up and we'll give you the
recipe at the end and we'll rate it but
like any good happy hour yeah so if you
get some money wisdom you get a little
pop culture update and you get a great
recipe oh something okay speaking of Pop
Culture oh boy
Instagram Instagram Kenneth is my yeah
it's my it's my it's my social media of
choice so people will send me clips all
the time which I so appreciate America
thank you for doing it because it's
fascinating money advice that's out
there so I saw this clip Ken and I would
love okay to have a discussion so let's
play this Instagram reel in 16 years
your daughter will not be able to buy a
house it will not be affordable for her
to buy a house unless you help her I
would argue that it is a Better Business
decision it is a better financial
decision for you to buy a house for her
it's an investment property it's a
rental property all of the money that
comes from that goes into an account and
that is her College number one and
number two that house is being paid for
by somebody else so then when she is 22
years old graduated from college you can
say your sweetheart here is the home
that you will never ever have been able
to afford if I had not bought it for you
16 years ago and I'm telling you right
now that is the best financial decision
rather than going to 529 whatever that
thing is college fund that is oh yeah
pleat and total bull I agree I'm telling
you right now going ahead and buying a
house as an investment that is the best
thing that you can do for your children
and I'm not selling anything I own
because I wish I'd kept everything I
ever bought
yeah wow a lot there fascinating she was
a bit of a machine gun there she knew
what she wanted to all right come over
to the world
um myth number one first thing she said
that's incorrect and it's just absolute
emotional hyperbole is that your
daughter won't be able to buy a house it
won't be affordable two on her own
that's fear mongering and that's that's
kind of playing into this whole you know
uh upper class versus lower class that's
a little bit of middle class Warfare
because she's making a point uh but
that's exaggerated and it's not true
secondly
um what she's prescribing there is most
likely I don't have any other context do
you know this person no no I don't have
any other context but she's probably
saying take on debt so let's say an
American family's got a bunch of debt
and then they were to take what she were
to say is Gospel now they're going to go
get a second mortgage and under the
guise of well this is really really
smart so it's incomplete advice so
there's two things things right out of
the game okay so number one yes I'm with
you on the fear thing I'm like no that's
just not I just I just am not yeah I
don't agree uh number two yes getting on
that second mortgage where I'm like man
now if you ever pay cash for it that's a
different discussion but people think in
the like the real most people wouldn't
be able to and yeah but people think
with real estate they're like oh yeah
it's you know you just buy it and
someone else will pay the mortgage and
it's no big deal yeah it's a part-time
job when you have other properties like
and risky and risky because what if you
don't have anyone to fill it and then
who's gonna pay the mortgage so uh third
thing the 529 is a wonderful investment
vehicle she makes it out like it's some
sort of piece of crap and they're both
like oh yeah I don't know 529 it's so
stupid well if it's not that's not right
529 is a wonderful investment vehicle
and it can be used multiple ways so you
know again the poo pooing what's normal
and the fear-mongering here this is
incomplete however all right those are
three things I didn't like okay give me
what you did like Kenneth here's the
caveat all right right the caveat is
if you have no debt all right you have
no debt the Ramsay way
and you can put a sizable down payment
on a home a future home and in in the in
the context of what she's saying for
your child versus
fund their college
I don't think that's foolish and and I
only say that to say you have to be
financially responsible like this is not
stressing you out financially you can
put a huge down payment on it so you're
going the amount of money I would put
towards their college is more than a 20
down payment
and we have no other debt therefore this
is not stressing us out
um in that situation it is a very
interesting idea because college has
increasingly got more expensive and less
relevant and that is true yes so you're
giving your kids some options to where
they could cash flow their way through
college with the rent is what she's
saying that's right well oh no they just
they work and so you've now given them
this long-term investment you've gifted
them this long-term investment it's
interesting I'm not recommending it or
endorsing it right but I at least want
to be an equal opportunity commenter
if you have the financial wherewithal
and you're not going into any kind of
risk and you're not assuming a very
large amount of debt right uh it's not
it's not a it's not a horrible idea but
the way they set it up is an incomplete
narrative yes that's a that's a great
way of putting it that's fair because
too I'm like when you transfer an asset
like a house there's a lot of things you
were talking about this earlier yeah you
gotta there's like a tax that there
could be tax implications if you're not
careful all this and yeah and the rental
income that you make is taxable like
it's just yeah all of this and I'm like
man I don't know it's just
I I don't know why I'm like it just it
feels uh like get an upma or something
like start investing and this is the
nature of social media people like this
can sway people with an incomplete
narrative and what you need to
understand is is that you're assuming
risk and you can't guarantee that you're
gonna have renters all the time there's
a lot of things that are that are at
play versus the 529 can be used in a
variety of ways towards qualifying them
so if they don't go to traditional
College they can still use the 529 for a
trade school which now is like you know
it could be past try to different
children all that so what yeah yeah but
college is it is a fascinating topic
right now because there's a part of me
though that I still am like that
transition from 18 to 21
still having a level of responsibility
still learning and growing like that
that is a I want to challenge you I know
I know but listen listen like that still
there is there is prose to that there
are but my question is my my is like
what is college going to look like in 15
years and I am putting money in a 529.
very different so what what is it going
to look like and I don't think you're
gonna feel nervous too yeah I get that
hey I got to tell you this yesterday
Entre leadership Master Series happening
downtown Nashville I took a question
from a business owner that operate big
like Pacos and big giant tractors and
things like that on construction sites
they're hiring kids straight out of high
school to operate these big machines I
mean kids are loving it they're making
as much as 55 60 000 very awesome right
out of high school
don't go anywhere more of your calls
coming up this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show we are
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five up next we
have Mark in Sacramento hey Mark welcome
to the show
hi
um I want to listen to you guys through
the YouTube highlights and uh my best
friend listens to you a lot
I have a question and my only debt that
I have is my home I owe 295 000. uh I
have a good interest rate to me at 2.14
I have a small investment account
through Edward Jones of about 14
000 and then I have cash of about a
hundred thousand and I want to do
something with a hundred thousand to
invest it but I
I'm very leery to listen to people on
Instagram and follow them and do what
they recommend and I was hoping for some
guidance
some wisdom right there yeah don't take
Financial advice straight off of
Instagram yeah
um okay Mark so you have you have no
other debts you have a lot of cash I
mean six figures of cash which is
awesome do you have anything in
retirement do you have any do you have a
Roth IRA open do you have a 401k at your
work
um no I don't the my investment account
was intended to be as a retirement okay
um my grandfather needed to pull some
cash in me he got penalized and that's
always been a fear of mine is
not being able to have access to my
monies that's all do you have the option
for a 401k through your or a raw through
your work
no not at the moment okay that's in the
works
um I work for the family business and so
okay I got you okay it's a matter of me
setting that up yeah and still a Roth
IRA could be an option so Mark I would
encourage you though to look into that I
understand being able to get to your
money
um is important to you and and I get
that but also you're gonna miss out on a
lot of growth and tax-free growth if
these accounts are wrapped in a Roth so
if you if it's not just a traditional
IRA but it's a Roth and if you get a
Roth 401k as well so there's just so
much opportunity for growth there for
retirement that I would recommend
looking into that so if I were you and I
woke up in your shoes
um I would take this hundred thousand
dollars and I would put some of it still
and just have in a money market account
for an emergency funds anywhere from
three to six months of expenses there I
would open up a Roth IRA and and I know
the 401K will be a little bit more
complicated within the family business
but once you get that up and running
funding some money into that and even
maxing that out for the year and then
taking the rest and saying okay what
else do I want to do is there you know
am I do I want to purchase a home soon
do I need to replace a car like what
else with this money
what what else could you do or could you
go and just invest it in just a standard
mutual fund just a growth stock mutual
fund as well so those are some options
but I would hate for you to miss out on
putting your money in some type of
retirement vehicle because of the growth
the tax-free growth that happens that
when you go to retire that oh it's it's
so nice to have so nice to have
yeah it really is
do you recommend a certain place that I
start my research you know I would sit
down with a smart investor Pro they are
investment professionals that we
actually recommend and they will sit
down with you and teach you and give you
options these people eat and breathe
this stuff so if you hold on the line
Austin will pick up and he'll get you uh
connected to one of our smart investor
pros and finds uh where on
ramseysolutions.com that you can find
that and help you navigate that so I
would sit down yeah with an investment
professional and look at that but
um but it's a great question and I and I
appreciate your diligence in
the amount of saving and your yeah your
intentionality with all of this but I
think that there is some stuff that you
could do with that hundred thousand that
will really really help you in the
future yeah and Mark I would just Echo
what Rachel says but when you sit with
and I want you to interview at least two
or three of our smart investor Pros we
recommend that because we want to make
sure that you have a good fit and feel
with them and they need to have that
chemistry with you because they should
have the heart of a teacher that's why
we work with them and we hold them to
that standard and we want you to be able
to understand everything that you would
do so when you sit with them come in
there pencil and paper lots of questions
ask the specifics I'm scared of this
because and and take those real
scenarios to them and let them walk you
through to the point that you go okay
now I understand and knowledge is is
wonderful antidote to fear so take those
questions decide who you feel is the
best partner with you because you're the
one making the decisions not them I just
want to make sure that you know that and
then you're going to be fine you're so
disciplined and measured that you just
need a good guide yeah and that's a
great point and any of these industries
when it comes to your money that is
specific whether it's investing tax
Insurance having someone on your side
that you actually like and trust versus
someone that's slimy and you're like I
don't trust them it's not worth working
with people that you don't like I mean
honestly so yeah I think that's a great
point so Mark yeah get a couple people
names of some smartvestor pros interview
them and and hopefully they can help
guide you when it comes to looking at
some retirement options all right next
up we have Janelle in Orlando hey
Janelle welcome to the show
Hi how are you guys doing today we're
doing well how can we help
yeah
um so I my husband and I are wondering
if we should sell our house to pay off
our debt that's just taking up most of
our like income yeah okay so how much
debt do you guys have
just in revolving credit card debt and
personal loan we have 95 000 and then we
have like 20 000 student loans 33 000
and a um
our car loan and so it's just a lot yeah
yeah that is a lot how much you guys
make a year
uh my husband uh makes about 135 a year
um and he also gets VA benefits okay
um and your house tell me about that how
much is your
wheel 4.95
um our realtor is saying that we should
list it at 675 to 685
and that would probably bring us home
with just enough to put like 20 000 in
savings
um and pay like all of our debt or most
of our debt off completely
yeah okay
we would get a rental in the same
neighborhood to try to keep our kids in
the school systems that they're in right
now
um and the thing is that our you know we
have family members that are used to be
our Realtors are very close to us that
are pushing back and saying that because
we have a lower interest rate we should
try to get a HELOC or something to like
fight it out and try to make a little
more room in our budget but right now
like we the amount of money that we pay
out to credit cards and all this stuff
is um
you know my husband made so much money
and he I mean we don't see any of it we
have nothing you know are you upside
down in the cars
if you only have one car that's it's
it's just the Jeep um and we I I
wouldn't say upside down did you get for
it would probably break even
um we could probably make even for it
it's 33 000. we haven't explored the
option of of selling it yet well that'll
relieve a car payment how much is that
car payment a month
six hundred dollars yeah so that's gonna
that would feel good just to get that
out of the way do you guys have any
savings
we have the the baby step number one
that keeps getting depleted because we
have had thing after thing happen with
us with like that that bills and all
these things and we didn't have and how
much how much did you really want yeah
for sure how much is your mortgage
payment
um it's 2700 2700 okay
oh man
um
yeah you're it's
well here's the deal we we don't always
recommend just selling your house to get
out of debts that if there's a way for
you to stay in it because you know if
there's a way for you to stay in it then
it's it's not the thing that's going to
make or break you yes could you sell it
and wipe all of this out and have money
and savings and feel completely
different at the end of the day
absolutely but in y'all's mortgage
payment I mean it's it's climbing up
there
um with that you know that 25 30 that we
talk about so you're kind of still in
that range
um
for you Julie I'm sorry Janelle what's
what is your do you guys want to sell do
you want to sell just get out who cares
what your family says
that's the thing it's such a beautiful
big house but we value things that our
experiences more and my husband's you
know feels like there's a lot of
pressure on his shoulders and so we just
part of a big part of this once we just
wipe it and be done yeah let's pay all
of that off sure okay so there's there's
the factor of having completely that
piece so Janelle that could be a an
option yeah for you guys looking at
don't listen to your family and and look
to see okay work we do
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios this is the Ramsey show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money I'm
Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with best-selling author and
ramps personality Ken Holtman so we are
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're talking
about careers
yeah where's your money yeah so work
life yeah like a big Shuffle how do you
make more money well getting promoted is
one way changing jobs you know maybe
you're in a toxic situation so I'm here
to answer any of those work questions
and and Rachel's here on the money stuff
and of course we have quite a few
opinions on any relationship stuff as
well I mean we are married we well not
married each other no but we have kids
yes and uh but you never know new people
I said we were married and I was like
wait a second we're not
how many years for you guys oh 24 and a
half thank you very much very nice yeah
I've got the silver anniversary coming
up next year yeah you do oh I may need
to I may need to consult with you on the
uh on the Rock You Know You Gotta
upgrade it at 25. wow really isn't that
a thing I didn't know there was an
actual time frame but well 25. Stacy
probably won't be mad about it the woman
deserves a lot let's just be honest
putting up with me for that long my
goodness gracious so there you go it can
be done that's right how long have you
and Winston been married it'll be 13. 13
three kids 13 three kids yep you're in
the middle we're brilliant we know
exactly we know we know all the answers
to everything I'll tell you what we do
know a lot of both of us we both know
what not to do that's right so we can
guide you from that we learned some
lessons yeah boy have we all right so
first up here on the phones we got
Sheila and Pensacola welcome to the show
hi hello how can we help
I am calling because I inherited uh our
IRA account for my husband he passed
from covet in October last year oh and
it is driving me nuts watching this
account just go down
I am not a gambler
and I need to know where can I put this
money
to where it won't be losing and I won't
be
I won't have to pay any penalties or
taxes or anything just put it somewhere
safe would a CD be good
she's like how how old are you
I am 55 55 okay oh that's young 55 years
young Sheila come on
so Sheila I gotta I wanna I don't feel
like it I know I know some days I don't
feel as young as I am but you know it is
what it is hey here's what I want you to
to hear you just told Rachel and I
that you're not a gambler
no but if you pull that money out of
that IRA
you are gambling because you've not lost
any money in that Ira despite the
balance that you're seeing day in and
day out you've not lost any of that
unless you pull it out but right now the
stock market is in a true bear situation
it's a bear market and a lot of money on
the sidelines because of interest rates
going up and very smart money people who
play the stock market which affects your
retirement account it's real but they're
just on the sidelines right I just saw
an article today trillions of dollars I
think it's four trillion dollars of cash
it's been pulled out of the market
recently and it's sitting there it's
gonna come back
and what you have to do and Dave has
said this for years Rachel stay on the
roller coaster and right now that roller
coaster is in a big dip but it is going
to come back and I want you to look at
it this way uh any any money that you
were to put in that not to say that you
are but I'm looking at my 401k and I'm
looking at it going every time I
contribute to that Rachel in this bear
Market I am getting stocks and at a and
those mutual funds at a deal yeah deal
I'm getting them at a discount because
when the when the roller coaster comes
back up Sheila and it's going to
well you're going to be sitting pretty
so my recommendation is stop looking at
it every day and then and then and then
play to who you really are and you don't
want to gamble so don't pull that money
out that would be gambling yeah and the
taxes and everything else and the
penalties that you'll have Sheila it's
it's not worth it it is not worth it so
ride the roller coaster uh Warren
Buffett one of my favorite quotes he
always says is that people make the
worst money decisions when they're drunk
or when they're afraid yup that's true
and fear is a very and I understand that
when you're looking at the numbers
you're like oh my gosh yeah but listen I
I wouldn't even at 55 years old stay in
it because it's just like Ken said we
believe in the American economy enough
that it's gonna come back it may take
time it's gonna take time
but but wait it out because when it does
you're gonna feel it again and you're
gonna wish that 2022 Sheila hadn't
touched it because you're going to look
up at 62 65 68 and have an IRA that your
husband that I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
for your loss
um pass to you that that you're gonna
have that to to be able to retire and to
live off of the interest off of that and
so I would not put it in a CD you're not
going to make anything yes it feels safe
and if you were if you were older if you
were 75 80 you know this could be a
different discussion of what you do but
you're still you're still young you're
55 so you got some years
thanks for the call all right up next is
Bob in Sacramento hey Bob welcome to the
show
thank you yes how can we help
um I am buying a house
um
the sale price is 5 30 is what we're
paying 530k okay my question is
um
putting the proceeds from the house on
selling all of that proceeds into the
down payment I'm going to end up with
about a two hundred thousand dollar loan
um I have
about 337
000 in
IRA and 401K mostly all stocks that are
all going south right now
um my question is is my better off
paying that and and
knocking that loan down or not doing
that because none of it is locked so I'm
gonna have to pay
you know pay taxes on it yeah and
penalties no no no no you're fine you've
got a huge down payment on that house
you only have two hundred thousand
dollars left you've been disciplined at
this point you can pay that off sit on
those stocks and mutual funds don't
touch them let them continue to ride the
roller coaster like our last caller
you're in the dip right now and it's
going to come back up and my goodness
that's a tremendous congratulations
that's a tremendous down payment
yeah it's amazing you don't have a 200
000 rates are still historically low
even if even if they're a bit above six
I don't know what they are today but yes
it's still you know you're in great
financial shape with that down payment
yeah so Bob no I would I would not touch
retirement uh if these were just
standard mutual funds you know then or
just you had single stocks or something
you know we could look at a different
option but no it's not worth Cashing Out
retirement even though I appreciate your
um intensity to to get this house payout
paid off I still would not do not touch
retirement to do it so thanks for the
call this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com Ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show we are
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
so when it comes to being intentional
having goals knowing what you want in
life it can be really hard when you
think okay I want to you know win with
my money I want to win in my
relationships I want to have a better
spiritual walk but if you don't have the
right tools if you don't have the right
guidance it can be very difficult to
either set those goals or to follow
through with them so that's why I am so
excited to introduce the new 2023 Ramsay
goal planner so this is beautiful number
one the cover of it see that you see
that gold you could kill a person see
that gold it's so heavy so meaty just
gorgeous just gorgeous very nice but uh
me George Campbell and Dr John deloney
have new monthly teachings here in the
Ramsey goal planner to help you when it
comes to your financial goals your
relationship goals and your spiritual
goals and you get everything you get you
get monthly check-ins you get the
calendar everything that a good planner
has and those of you that love planners
will love this one so make sure to check
it out they always sell out quickly
every year but you can get yours at
ramseysolutions.com
planner so you got your monthly View and
then you got your daily view you get
some teaching from each of you yeah some
notes uh I can tell you what I like
about it the tabs ah you're a tab guy
I'm a tab guy yeah love a good tab I
I've always loved a Bible that had the
Taps oh do you know what I mean so good
and boy it's just very easy and it is
sturdy my goodness that's good I know
what you need I don't know how much this
weighs do I it's very impressive it's a
that's my point of saying that is that's
not your flimsy uh uh uh uh uh calendar
that you get at the convenience store or
the uh do they sell those at the
convenience store I'm struggling right
now I don't know the pharmacy 80s look
at the pharmacy you know what I almost
said you just went I almost said dime
story
kid yeah
2022 yeah you go get yourself a
milkshake and a planner sit at the
counter
the five and dime story do you even know
what that is no I don't never heard it
before in her life no I've heard of it I
just think I don't know if I I'm trying
to keep it old school for her folks
there's a guy you always do that
appreciates the five and times that's
your spiritual gift yeah and always
bringing us back something old something
on something new
oh gosh all right next up we have
Brittany in Tulsa Oklahoma hey Brittany
welcome to the show
thank you guys I'm so grateful you took
my call
um so my my question uh kind of boils
down to uh how to provide best for my
five kids I uh recently
um in the last couple years have become
a single mom
um support has been cut off it's it's
been more and more increasingly
difficult to
co-parent with my ex
um and I had a side business that I had
built up to just kind of help my family
out of the last few years brought in
twelve thousand dollars last year but
now I have to be a fully supported
single mom
um I no longer get to homeschool my kids
I
um it's kind of got a bit of a struggle
um but my current job I make 16 an hour
I am grateful for the opportunity it was
a former client of mine for my other
business who knows how important my
business is and wanted to
give me that opportunity to be able to
take a day off to continue building that
that for my children but
um I'm just struggling with
trying to figure out the next step or
how how best yeah sure can I ask you
what your business is the side business
okay so I'm I'm a professional organizer
um in my current job I am a fire and
Flood Restoration technician okay and
what do you make as an organizer is it
by project is it hourly or both it's
hourly
um I currently make fifty dollars an
hour
um in my business forgive my ignorance
is this like uh is this organizing
people's closets pantries houses garages
or anything ninety percent ninety
percent of what I do with actually I
consider it
um the psychological emotional side of
it because I have a very strong
philosophy if you need me to come back
six months from now I failed you oh wow
so I I I I do not
I do not have the same mentality that
some of my organizer friends have
um I want to get them from top to bottom
front to back if we go through
everything you own you should not need
me again your house should work for you
to such a degree
so I think you're the perfect person to
get out of this this this this situation
you're in uh obviously there's uh
there's some deadbeat stuff going on uh
from your ex and not paying support and
all that stuff we can't fix that we
can't control that so we got to focus on
what you can control and a person like
you that is a professional uh organizer
and helping others understand
organization you're really well equipped
for this I want to start with that
encouragement
um but but I want to look at not just
your income I want Rachel to help you
through maybe what your expenses are and
she can really help you with that but I
am curious to know if you feel like
um that you're able to make another 12
000 or maybe more with this day off from
your from your former customer I'm
curious about that do you feel like you
could still make 12 000 on the side or
even more with your current schedule and
responsibilities
um it takes more
I I I I can't okay most of my my
organizing gigs are during the week
during the day which is when my of
course so the answer is you're limited
chaos okay so are you able to do that
they're using that day off too to do it
or are we I am taking I what I do is I
if I get a client then I take I take a
day off from my current job I just tell
them hey I won't be in tomorrow hey I
won't be in Thursday
um and they've been very understanding
but my only current way to get clients
at this point is Thumbtack and I haven't
had a lot of I haven't had a lot of
traffic there okay so I'm gonna I want
Rachel to help you on budgeting and
spending and all that I want to I want
to to transfer to you to her but I would
say this you with your abilities your
skill set and experience you should be
making more than 16 an hour and one of
the things I want to challenge you on is
in our current economy
um I mean we're talking about targeting
Walmart just to use two big box examples
uh our paying people at starting rates
of 19 18 20 21 22 dollars an hour and
and I think that's what you've got to be
doing as a single mom of five babies
um you've got to be doing everything you
can to bring in the most income in to
get financially to a place where maybe
we can come back to that business and I
want to encourage your heart to say yeah
if you've got to press pause on this
side business for a season it is a
season not a sentence it is not dead
it's not over it's not gone forever I
want to encourage your heart on that
yeah and
Brittany because it's a pretty unique
thing that you have the flexibility of
your current job to be able to kind of
call in and say hey I'm going to take
tomorrow off because you're able to get
paid 50 an hour at this other gig and
you can kind of swap so if there's
another situation that you pay more than
16 an hour so again kind of what Ken was
saying the The Big Box stuff so whether
it's Walmart or Target or something if
there is another option career-wise you
get paid more per hour and still have
that flexibility to pull in that side
job because it's paying you so much
that's ideal so are you uh Brittany are
you guys are you behind on any bills
right now are you currents what's your
debt tell me kind of your situation
I'm currently living in an unstable
housing situation which I am actively
working daily trying to find a new one
uh I could be homeless by the 16th but
I'm not sure about that yet
um
okay
so the the house is in
my ex's and my name okay but
unfortunately uh
some legal stuff to judge the judges
declared that I am now responsible for
everything you haven't been paying child
support which would help towards that so
if I don't pay by the fifth I am almost
9 15. so is this an appointment on a new
mortgage or just a rent a house another
mortgage on the on the house okay so I
don't want you behind on that so for you
and the kids do you do you have the
income to pay it or you you don't right
now
uh at this point I do not have what he
said I owe which there is debate he's
he's behind mumps and he's saying that I
owe him 5 000 in order to stay in the
house and that's
not feasible so
um I am working through that with my
lawyers and
we're going to get you connected to one
of our financial coaches is our gift
because they can walk you through the
minutian detail that we cannot on this
phone call so hang on the line we're
going to get you connected FPU
everything that we can give you right
now to help you out hang on Mama Bear
you're gonna get through this we're
gonna get you connected to one of our
financial coaches thanks for calling
[Music]
thank you
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of Ramsay Solutions on the debt-free
stage we have Adam and Jennifer welcome
you guys hey guys thanks for having us
absolutely where you guys from We're
from Muscle Shoals Alabama awesome well
I guess you're on the stage for one
reason one reason only that's right
that's right we're gonna do a debt free
scream today debt free congratulations
you guys we're excited okay so how much
debt did you pay off 150 000. nice
making what kind of income during that
time like 160 to 220. how long did it
take by the way that was over about five
years and 10 months five years 10 months
and what was the debt it was our house
this is our house did it oh you're good
completely debt free completely debt
free amazing you guys so what happened
five five and a half years ago that made
you think ah we went we want to pay off
our house so that was how long we've had
our house for that was when we bought
our house in Fall of 2016. and our
debt-free journey actually started in
2013 yeah
um that's when we got married we
graduated with student loans of about
200 000 and we actually
um in early 2016 finished paying those
off and did it at free scream at the old
Studio okay yeah and so when we bought
our house we knew we didn't want debt
forever we didn't want a 15-year
mortgage even so we made a commitment to
paying it off early and we didn't know
how long that would be but um we stayed
diligent and just paid off as we could
and here we are you know 70 months later
and we're debt free again second time
second time so you guys you guys got
some experience it's just a new building
new stage we've done this yeah right
yeah we had to come check out the campus
and we kind of said we're going to go do
another debt free stream and I mean yeah
I didn't have to convince her very much
to uh to come back so I love it yeah so
we do celebrate people that can't pay
off all their Consumer Debt and then
some people either come back which I
don't know if we've had many
mortgage is paid off so I'm curious for
you guys what's the difference in your
in the feeling of paying off all that
student loan the Consumer Debt and yes
that versus paying off your mortgage
it is different the journey itself was
different too because the first round
was so intense we were very gazelle
intense everything that we made went to
our loans where this time it was more
over the Long Haul and so the diligence
and consistency of we weren't seeing
those huge chunks going at it every
single month like our student loans
because we had other things going on we
had two kids in that time we upgraded
two cars we had retirement savings you
know that four five and six is slower
um so it's a little bit more that like
slow and steady feeling yep it was your
down payment on that house it was about
40 I think our house at the time was 194
when we bought it oh wow good for you
yep amazing you guys okay so what what
was the hardest part of paying off your
house because people are hearing that
and they're thinking yeah that's crazy
because how old are you guys you're 35
35 and not a house payment yeah
incredible yeah I think the hardest part
probably would be not really it in that
life creep you know come in there and
and also like Jennifer said with the
student loans we had you know it was
really you'd get you know having that
reward of of getting those big payments
every month and even you know over the
five years and 10 months there were
plenty of months when we didn't have
much extra to go towards the house and
so not we had to just kind of encourage
each other more and
um there weren't really it was more slow
but even even the slow version was still
we had to zoom out a lot and be like hey
this is this is awesome we're really you
know we're doing a great thing here and
this is not you know normal like we say
like you guys always say this is not
this is we're weird and um I think we've
I think we've been doing the the Ramsay
way for so long we kind of forgotten
that it's it's not normal like for us
this is what we've been doing pretty
much our whole marriage
um but there's people out there just
getting started who are just trying to
figure it out
um so we just that's why we wanted to
come back to be an encouragement to
those people that you know are just
getting started
um that need to hear that it can happen
um and we were just thinking back how
you know we couldn't be here with a paid
off house if we hadn't done the work
back several years ago if we hadn't paid
off our student loans then we certainly
wouldn't be here we probably could have
bought a house then and been four
hundred thousand dollars in job then and
it wouldn't have been anywhere right and
the financial side of that you're
exactly right and I think the emotional
side the character qualities what is
built within you when you go and pay off
Consumer Debt and you sacrifice
everything you were talking about it was
so intense all that sacrifice that same
type of of motivation there right like
that that changes who you are yeah so
when you lead into baby steps four five
six and seven as we're talking about
that like that is a slower pace and
that's what we tell people you know you
can kind of let your foot off the gas
you kind of go from that intensity to
consistency you know and it's just oh
that's good yeah hold on that's really
good that was tweetable I knew that was
absolutely a tweet right there that is
fantastic and I have a follow-up
question on that that's really really
good how much did the previous Journey
allow you to be so automated the way you
kind of describe yeah I mean we already
had our budget in place and it took a
lot more tweaking and talking about once
we finish that first section
um but we had the budget in place we had
our communication in place you know
that's that's been a part of our
marriage this this whole time is being
on the same page about our money and and
that was huge starting out our marriage
that way and we've just really kind of
built on that this whole time for sure
yeah I gotta ask how much is that house
worth you think about 290 come on now
yeah how's that feel big it feels good
it was really good
only about a month or two you know into
it so we've I think it hasn't set in yet
even like yeah we're still just now
figuring out like what do we do now what
does our budget look like now that we
don't have that did you guys take your
shoes off and uh do what Dave says I
wonder how many people actually go out
and feel the grass oh yeah we did does
it feel different I need to know I think
people want a difference
feels it feels good that's good all
right and you guys killed it I mean
within five years because most people on
average doing this it's about seven
years to pay off the house is what we
see so you guys and that's what we kind
of thought it probably would be like
seven or eight years you know we weren't
really like pushing it real hard but
then um like I said we had two kids in
that time
yeah so great yeah well congratulations
you guys what's the secret when it comes
to paying off your house it's hard just
in it's hard to put it just in one thing
I think just consistency like we said I
mean I think everyone says it but the
budget like you really have to know what
you're spending to know then where it
can go and how you can cut back
especially now I mean we look at our
grocery budget right now and you just I
mean when the groceries are so expensive
at the store you wouldn't even notice if
you didn't have a budget to notice how
much more you're spending right now
um so that really helps you stay
consistent every single month looking at
it and seeing where you're money's going
I love it I know everybody says it but
it's kind of oh yeah
the more you focus on the budget then
you can start to see the Hope in the
situation yeah and see the progress
you're making then right then you know
what's left over and you know exactly
what you're doing with that leftover
money while you guys are are absolutely
incredible so impressive mid-30s no debt
at all not even a mortgage payment so
bring up the two little ones you guys
ready
names and ages this is Brooks and he's
four and a half and this is Elise and
she's two and a half oh I like her she's
got a little girl she's got a little uh
little juice
all right you guys ready absolutely
amazing all right so we have Adam and
Jennifer Brooks and Elise from motion
Alabama paid off a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars which includes their
house making 160 a year did it in five
years all right you guys okay let's hear
your debt free scream three two one
we're dead free
amazing oh absolutely incredible
oh
it's possible it is possible that's what
it's you know it's fun you look at those
two little ones Brooks and Elise
who's I'm her new number one fan by the
way yeah you love her I love her she's
fantastic but those kiddos have no idea
uh the sacrifice and then the
unbelievable future they have the Legacy
that Mom and Dad is gonna they will be
passing on to them that's that's why we
do the show that's right for families
like that so cool
Morris cotton Todd and those kids the
house that they're growing up in is
incredible parents that took control oh
congratulations you guys in America it's
possible for you too make the decision
do something different this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s.com blinds.com 100 satisfaction
guaranteed means even if you miss
measure or pick the wrong color they'll
remake your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promo codes they run every month you'll
save even more use promo code Ramsay to
get the best deal today's question comes
from Shirley in Wisconsin how do you
feel about women being stay-at-home moms
and not bringing in an income after they
have a baby do you feel like that is an
unwise financial decision first of all I
think it's fan freaking tastic
I think it's the greatest role
in the world
to be a mom to be a full-time mom say at
home mom however you want to Define it
my wife has been a stay-at-home mom for
large portions there have been Seasons
where she has worked
um and so into that second part of the
question do you feel like that is unwise
as a financial decision the answer is no
because there there are other decisions
other lifestyle choices
that we make that causes to have
Financial stress but to be a
stay-at-home mom the act of being a
stay-at-home mom is not an unwise
decision in any way now if you've got to
change some Financial things that you've
done but that's something you did
previous to a little one on the way so I
I think I hear the spirit of this Rachel
and and just as a male I wanted to sound
off just to say
um
you know I hope no one ever looks down
at that role it's an important season
and no one should shame a mom for
wanting to work at home uh because
that's what it is it is working at home
I mean it's not like you're eating
bonbons yeah I'm like oh my God you're
not staying anywhere you were running so
would you add to that as a professional
model yeah I mean I would say you're
saving on Child Care yeah think about
all I mean they they there was a study
that was run and it was basically like
all of the mileage the average mom
drives uh the food that she cooks uh the
house that she cleans all the child care
provide all of it and it's like 1.2
million dollars or something nearly if
you were to Outsource all of that which
I know you can't do that but the errands
that Stacy runs for us all of it not
just for me you hold your family
together I mean it is so I think that
Stacy is the CEO of the Coleman
household and I have no problem saying
that oh for sure I don't feel weak I
don't feel less than I mean she's the
chief executive officer there's no
question now we do so it's fascinating
too the whole stadium all about the
discussion when it comes to money and
even when you talk about debt because
there are a lot of moms where they are
motivation to get out of debt is to go
home because they're like if I don't
have these bills I don't need my income
uh and then for other people while
they're getting out of debt a
stay-at-home mom may say hey I'm gonna
go work part-time uh to make some income
to get out of debt even faster right so
like there's always seasons of life
regardless but no as this if there's a
black and white question of is it unwise
unwise decision when it comes to
finances no or family No in fact it's a
gift it is a huge gift so um thanks for
the question though shortly all right go
into the phones at this hour we have
Jared in Birmingham hey Jared welcome to
the show
hey guys how are you we're doing well
how can we help
good well
um my wife and I have been working the
baby steps and we just moved into our
first house in July nice congratulations
yeah well it's been great we've enjoyed
it however the past week we developed a
leak in our crawl space so and uh We've
have water restoration company and
insurance adjusters already come out and
uh basically determined that they're
going to pull up all of our Hardwoods
and do a lot of renovation
um to the home where's the where'd the
water come from
I came from a hot water heater
um basically the copper pipe eroded and
there was a leak for a little while and
they didn't catch any damage an
inspection or anything
and they they did they didn't catch it
so and it has ruined your Hardwoods
or your floor most of our hard yeah most
of our Hardwoods have buckled up
um so they basically determined that
they're gonna replace all the hardwoods
throughout the hole okay this is just
for America can we just can we just stop
for a second we're gonna get you a
question this is for America when
someone's like I just want to go buy a
house I just want to go buy a house it's
cheaper than renting this is what
happens to homeowners you get this crap
and it is expensive to own a home is
freaking expensive so Jared I am so
sorry this has happened to you but this
is this is why ownership it's it's great
and when you're in a financial position
to do it yes I would do it but this is
why you don't need to go buy a house
when you're living paycheck to paycheck
with no Savings in the bank because
you're freaking watching this could
happen this is it this is exactly what
happens but Jared it is gonna be okay
you're fine I'm using this as a teaching
lesson yeah
but you feel it so what's the question
how can we help well Mike I quick
question once you're out of pocket then
on this
um so our out-of-pocket will be a 3 000
deductible so we've got about four
months in our emergency funds maybe five
months which is how much so uh it's
about eighteen thousand dollars right
now
so what's your question
really the question is like we're really
excited about getting into investing and
you know baby steps four five and six
um but you know with this situation
going on we felt like we held off on
investing for so long we're just
wondering should we just kind of keep
holding hold out and keep stacking up
cash for the emergency fund or would it
be okay to go ahead and get started with
um some investing and just work through
this whole process while investing or
should we just holding on for a couple
more months no I would I would I would
be investing because you have an
emergency fund for emergencies in this
can you cash flow this or is this an
emergency for you
probably even cash flow this
um throughout this process or we could
just dip a little bit into the emergency
fund to take care of it yep that's what
I would do I would not stop investing
because you guys have enough margin here
with the emergency fund and you being
able to cash flow it no I wouldn't pause
I understand the hesitation of like oh
God this could be expensive and you know
or we're gonna put money Investments but
you guys are in a great spot Jared this
is why this is why you do what you do
with the emergency fund and everything
and being out of debt you have margin
with your income so no I would not pause
investing I would keep doing that and uh
you guys use the emergency fund too if
you need to this is what's funny people
emotionally I don't like using I don't
like either that's what my answer was I
just have to admit I'm like well if you
can cash flow it yes
but but but but this goes this is a
broader question we have a lot of new
people always watching and listening to
show so for new folks I actually uh
Jared hangless I want to ask Rachel to
talk about this
what defines the emergency and because
in this situation he was saying we
probably can cash flow but that would be
Jared I'm guessing that's a pretty
sizable budget adjustment in order to
cash flow is that true
right right yeah and see that's what I
want to ask you you've been teaching
this longer so now does that make an
emergency when he's got to make that big
of a budget adjustment well for me an
emergency is always when it's unplanned
right and it's unexpected well that's
this is it and this is it I mean this is
this is truly when you're like oh my
gosh this is come out this came out
without me why do I not want to touch
the emergency I don't either so if I was
Jared and we could cash flow it I
wouldn't touch it either and I would
just say hey okay I'll cut back on the
budget that's what I would want because
you can cut back from you know two three
months whatever whatever that whatever
it is for you guys Jared uh just the
cash flow because you're gonna have to
go and fill the emergency fund back up
so either way you're going to be moving
your budget so I'd rather have the pain
in the present and just do it not touch
the emergency but if he needs it it's
there if he needs it it's there right
like if this came in as a six thousand
dollar then I'd be like man can you cash
flow three pull three out of the
emergency fund you know kind of figure
it out but Jared we only got about 60
seconds but I want I want America to
hear how does it feel emotionally
because this sucks but to have the money
and not be stressed out beyond the fact
that it sucks how does that feel
it felt great I mean my wife and I we
just like looked at each other like of
course this would happen like just
moving into the house
we had so many moments you know where
we're just like hey this is why we've
you know worked this process through the
whole time with Dave Ramsey's right in
the plan so you know it's just like the
stress of the money is just kind of out
of the equation and it's just an
inconvenience you know that's right it
takes a crisis now you get to focus on
new Hardwoods
would you maybe cash flow some new
Hardwoods and maybe upgrade the quality
a little bit maybe or if in reason
within budget absolutely I would I
wouldn't dip in the emergency fund for
that specifically to upgrade that's
right uh but if you guys have the cash
flow to be able to upgrade and it's
something else you want yeah you get to
pick some new finishes Jared that's an
exciting part I see I knew you would
step up I didn't know how to say that
was beautiful yeah that's exciting hey
make it a date night
head on over to your local uh hardwood
dealer and make Mama happy
[Music]
thanks for hosting with me thanks to
James Ben Zach Andrew Austin everyone
there in the booth and thank you America
for listening this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsey show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey's Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios this is the Ramsey show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money I am
Ramsay personality Rachel Cruz
co-hosting this hour with ramp's
personality and best-selling author Ken
Coleman we're gonna have some fun all
right we're taking the money questions
we're going to take the General Life
pleasure we're gonna talk about your
work potentially some of your struggling
in your work uh maybe you feel like hey
I this inflation's got me down I need to
make some more money we want to help you
make more money many times that's
getting promoted maybe getting a better
job so I'm here to weigh in on maybe on
some of those questions and uh we're
just going to help you out we're going
to have a blast with you so give us a
shout yes at triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's a free call
anywhere in the country so first up we
have Neil in St Louis hey Neil welcome
to the show
hey how's it going we're doing well
thanks thanks for calling
that's good um well my question is
mainly about like focus and what I
should be
putting all my energy into with my life
because a lot has changed in the last
three years uh first uh five years ago I
got married and then um uh my business
has been growing year over year like
crazy and uh this year like we're just
killing it and uh nice congratulations
do you mind telling us about your
business what kind of business is it
I'm a birkenstone Nathan no kidding that
was my second job ever during a summer
between my freshman and sophomore year
working for a brick mason so I have a
special affinity for that I'm glad
business is booming
well yeah it's awesome and uh yeah I'm
about to hire my fifth and sixth guy
next week wow
and so during that time also while the
business is growing I've had uh five
kids in three years whoa whoa
twins adoption what happened
well yeah I had uh I had number one
number two and then three and four came
in the first two years and then uh
number five just came three months ago
oh
my goodness
how you doing Neil Neil have you slept
in the last five years
well my wife has me but I'm just kidding
no easy but we're a good team uh and we
love kids and uh we have a really good
system down for that and our kids are
great congratulations that's a blessing
your wife is fantastic congratulations
wow
so what's up and um what's the question
so my question is so when I knew this
was baby number five was coming we've
been blessed like our whole life with
whatever's coming at us you know and uh
we had a van and um I I wanted to donate
my van to somebody else because there
was someone in need and uh and I was
praying about this and uh but I needed a
van to come my way and also a big job to
come and cover that man you know so baby
number five comes the paycheck didn't
come in right away uh so I donated the
van I bought a van with a loan for uh
because I needed a bigger van than just
a Ford that can hold four I need to hold
five and uh so I have like 29 000 in
debt now and we don't really do debt and
uh and I have the money to cover it I
just want to know like but I also would
like to use that money for growing the
business and focusing on paying people
because I have a lot of money set aside
for always having payroll going you know
and um well it's the van is the van in
your name it's not a company van correct
or is it in your name
it's my end yeah
okay so what's the question you don't do
debt but you went out and did it so what
what what do you want us to tell you
should I pay the van off yes uh pay it
off right away yes if you have the money
but but it also sounds Neil like you're
you're mixing your business finances and
your personal finances because you said
I have the money but I could use that
for payroll in the business all that
that's why that's where things do what
that's part of the that's part of the
growth like I've hired the six people in
the last year and a half and uh and I my
business wasn't like set up officially
and I've been doing all that like
getting all like the like turning it
into an as like a corporation oh I got
you okay okay so it's all that's all
part of the transition I've been going
to different meetings with people and
like okay so let me look it up
officially all right so let me just ask
you very quickly do you have the twenty
nine thousand dollars in the bank right
now or in your personal account or is in
the in the company account you'd have to
do some moving around
yeah personal and Company account is the
same thing right now you know so yeah
okay but okay let me ask a better
question the 29 000 you've got that set
aside for What specifically for the
business
nothing specific just as a so I don't
okay well you don't have to pay it all
off at once although I would if you
could but I also want you to be
responsible because of the fact that
that is your retained earnings for your
business so I guess the official
question the answer is we want you to
pay it off as quickly as possible do you
have to pay it off today with twenty
nine thousand dollar uh payment uh if
you can and it doesn't hurt you or put
your company at risk yeah and that's
when Neil you really do I mean I know
you know this because you said you were
doing it but that's where separating
personal business is so important you
pay yourself out of the business and
then out of that that earnings right is
where you go and say okay here is our
family we have this amount but man I
yeah if it does I don't want to put your
work in Jeopardy I don't want you to
like do something and now you gotta you
can't pay someone or something like that
I want you to have your bases covered in
your business but I would get those
separated as soon as possible uh so that
it's a clearer answer for you to be able
to say with your wife we have this
amount in the bank as a family do you
guys have an emergency fund with your
family we're not including the business
uh yeah we got all that so I mean we
have probably
like 30 30 40 000. how much more do you
have what other retaining earnings do
you have in the business that's going to
help it stay afloat if you if you paid
off the van today let's just pretend
that 29 000 was gone
where does that put you in your business
um I'll probably have about 10 000 left
in the bank and then um but I have these
big jobs that I've been working on I
have it set up where I'm getting paid
like I'm probably getting 10 000 a week
from jobs coming in consistently for the
next six months you know like at least
and then yeah and I got a lot of jobs
coming in so I have consistent money
coming in all the time and I guess I'm
nervous that uh what if they'd stop
paying me or something goes wrong or
weird you know because it just all this
growth happening at once it's great but
yeah all right so be so be methodical
and I want to follow up on Rachel what
Rachel asked you do your your emergency
fund is separate from the 29 000 that
we've been talking about correct
everything's kind of lumped together
mixed together
I know it's mixed together what I'm
saying is when when she asks you do you
have an emergency fund and you said 30
or 40 000 that does not include the 29
that you would use yeah that's what I'm
getting at yeah okay what I would do is
in this situation
I would put
10 on the van today
let's let's let's juice this and get the
the loan down to 19 okay and then let's
commit to maybe another 10 each month
and let's see if we can put 10 each
month so within less than 90 days you've
paid off the van but we still hold some
money back I feel like that that's what
I do in this situation because you're
right you're in a construction world and
they can change things on you and money
can be late so I don't want you to use
it all but I would commit to 90 days or
less we pay that van yes and having that
plan and I think getting you going on it
is going to also force you to say okay I
gotta separate that personal business
and I know Neil it's been crazy so
congratulations you've had a lot of life
change like you said super awesome
marriage five kids growing business
that's awesome so thanks Neil for
calling make that payment today though
let's get that momentum going pay it
today this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting at this hour with
best-selling officer and Ramsay
personality in Coleman and it's a free
call anywhere in the country at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right up next we have Francis in
Cincinnati hey Francis welcome to the
show
hello thank you for having me absolutely
a little nervous no you're good you're
good how can we help
okay um I'll just give the basics so I
can work out the question
um my husband and I make 58 000 annually
we have 25
000 left in debt um let's see student
loans and well actually all student
loans
um we're on baby step two we have
roughly fifteen thousand dollars kind of
in Saving
and
um so it's a two-part question
um
I want to take all the money that we
have right now that was about nine grand
was gifted to us and six is from income
tax that came in late I want to take
that all right now and put it all to our
student loans but my husband wants to
wait till to see if the Biden stuff is
going to be like the student loan
forgiveness is going to go through which
I'm not thinking it will but he just
wants to see
um so in that way it's kind of burning a
hole in my pocket where
there's the second part of the question
uh sort of um we've been through a lot
of emotional things going on we just had
a miscarriage we're finding a new church
and we're also trying to go minimalism
in the home and we have a three-year-old
and a one-year-old and it's lots of
people in the home so I want to go on a
vacation I want to get a different car
because we're at the car I drive right
now is at 290 000 miles and it's great
but we also might need to get a new
vehicle so
I made some directions because I'm kind
of yeah emotionally all over the place
right now yes and you're tired
yes you're tired yep you're exhausted
um which is fair which is yeah very so
sorry we're hurting for you
um so sorry that you guys are going
through this period it's a lot um
answer this question if I were to wake
up in your shoes
um
I would
pay off this debt you guys have close to
half your annual income still in debt at
that 25 000. dollars so I would throw 14
000 at it and I would
really really focus the budget even
though you're exhausted and even though
you know gosh I feel like we're gonna
have to need a new car soon I'm I want
to go on a vacation
all of that is so real but I want you
guys to really really tighten up your
budget and pay off this debt because
what's going to happen Francis when this
debt is paid off suddenly your income's
going to go up because you're going to
not be it's going to be going out to
payments you're going to have margin
again you're gonna be able to breathe
you're gonna be able to save up more for
a fully funds and emergency fund and
there's just gonna be peace and when it
comes to the whole you know the bite and
forgiveness stuff like we've told people
it's not it's not a moral it's not a
right or wrong thing
um but I wouldn't wait on it and there's
claiming that you can do a refund if you
pay it off that you can go back so if
excuse me
if it goes through you can always go and
do the refund if that's what you guys
want but I would not sit and wait on
this to go through because there's a lot
of opinions right and well time will
tell time will tell what happens
um but I would not sit and wait on them
on what they're going to do I would be
proactive in your own life and you guys
pay this off and you guys need some
momentum and you need some quick wins
and some rest right like and I know with
when we're paying off debt we talk about
being very intense uh that you're not
going out to eat you're not doing
anything but find some time Francis
because you have a one or three year old
so you're exhausted so find something
for you and your husband to go at nights
it's like yeah even if you get a sitter
for an hour and you guys just drive yeah
and just do nothing but just have a
break so make sure that you guys can
sustain
um yourselves during this but this is
possible you I don't know if you can
even work a side hustle or you could
pick something up because but I want
this debt gone as soon as possible
regardless of of what Biden does
well okay so I guess another I guess a
follow-up question is so we have
um we have a car like I said we have a
Toyota Highlander that's at 290 000 and
you know these things do awesome we've
probably run to 300 and my husband was
just just for looking looking at
different Vehicles you know just to try
to repair not repair but replace this
one
and part of me wants to run it into the
ground pardon me wants to get you know
either a Camry or Corolla or something
smaller but then the other part of me
just like we still have that money and I
would rather go to debt I'd rather not
have any of the other things that it
could be necessary and and then also I
how do I get back on the budget we both
have been emotionally drawn and I'm it's
hard for me to even like think to
function to have like dinner on the
table at night so yeah we've been going
out to eat like for dinner you know and
that's
emotionally where I am so it's
yeah are you guys on the same page
Francis because it's sounding like you
know he doesn't want to do this you want
to do that he's looking up cars you want
to run it into the grounds like well we
both have it's kind of like we've both
just been trying to figure this out
trying to figure out whether we should
ride the car out we both have agreed on
it and then we'll come back to this
point it's something that we keep like
running into yeah it's the same point
that we both like yeah it's not looking
like actively it's just sure okay okay
that's great that's great I just wanted
to ask because I think part of this too
is you guys as a couple being on the
same page and playing through it because
it is going to be exhausting Francis but
here's the deal too and then can you
jump in but we hear these stories all
the time and we have people stand on
that debt-free stage and it's not easy
right if it was easy everyone would be
doing it and so the exhaustion that you
feel is Justified because you feel that
but also it's expected in this because
to pay off debt there's a level of
sacrifice and I don't know if you get
the crock pot out and you look on Sunday
night and say we're having chicken we're
having rice and beans on Tuesday we're
having Mexican on Wednesday and we're
going back to chicken in the crock pot
Thursday like like just planning out and
having not letting your emotions take
over every decision and really being
intentional about stuff is going to help
but go ahead Ken yeah I I just if I
could be an older brother for a second I
want to encourage you I don't want you
to feel in any way that I'm that I'm
getting on you but I'm gonna tell you
that I think it's totally understandable
that you feel so exhausted that cooking
is the last thing on your mind I get it
and I get why you went out to eat but I
think today that has to stop because
here's what I know
your heart is hurting and stress isn't
going to help it heal faster but I'll
tell you that peace will
Financial Peace and the emotional and
the mental peace that comes with that
will allow you to heal faster but
Financial stress
will hamper the healing
I know that I know that and so what I'm
asking you to do is for you two to to
draw strength from each other
to draw strength from the peace that
comes with the plan that we teach
and decide today decide today all right
we're going to actually change the way
we live yes I'm exhausted but I'm going
to press through this because going out
to eat isn't going to heal the
exhaustion do you understand what I'm
saying so now you got to choose we've
already made the decision you know what
we didn't do we didn't actually do it we
decided but we didn't do it
and I think Rachel's right I think
making these moves are is going to give
you some momentum behind the decisions
that you guys desperately want to make
but now you gotta actually do it I hope
that encourages you because on the other
side of this it's tremendous peace
it is it is and Francis like this isn't
um this isn't forever right a lot of
this and you look and you guys can
crunch these numbers but you have a
great savings and again if you throw it
at the debt all of this you guys could
have this paid off in less than 12
months like if you guys really really
focus and again maybe picked up some
income do what you have to do and what
your life could look like in three years
oh you would have an emergency fund a
new car you get to go out to eat again
like I mean what it's not going to take
that long to build up to be out of debt
build up an emergency fund all of it but
hang on a line Francis Austin's gonna
pick up and I want to give you guys a
year subscription to Financial Peace
University which has every dollar plus
with it
um I want you and your husband to sit
down and do this together and the budget
is frustrating but give yourself three
months okay it's not gonna be great next
month not the next month by December
January you're gonna get the budget
going you guys are gonna have this debt
paid off in less than a year thanks for
calling
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show going to
the phones we have Thomas in Fort Smith
Hey Thomas welcome to the show
Hi how are you we're doing well thanks
how can we help
all right so I was trying to find out
how I could I guess get a bigger shovel
to get at the situation I'm in I'm 28
and I have twenty three thousand dollars
in debt
um ten thousand of it is student loans
five of it is a car loan
and I've got about five in collections
and then about
uh I'd say a thousand in a personal loan
and then
uh I guess miscellaneous the other stuff
I I don't know off the top of my head
what do you do for a living now
uh so I work at a wholesale distribution
center we sell electrical bars for
electricians so are you in sales
customer service
uh so I'm a driver so what they do is
they key in orders they and then I load
the material up and take it to the job
site and stuff like that okay so you're
so you deliver parts and things of that
nature how much do you make Thomas
uh 16.50 an hour okay are you full-time
like 40 hours a week yeah yes
okay so the answer to this is is either
a part-time job or a better full-time
job or both right so a I'm going to get
I'm going to add a a part-time job uh B
I'm going to uh uh I'm gonna well I just
messed up my whole line of order it
doesn't matter it's all three of those
those are your options so I'm either
going to add a part-time job I'm going
to get a better day job uh or I'm going
to do both those are the three options
so do you have the time
based on your responsibilities in life
anything to add a part-time job add
maybe 20 hours 30 hours a week
possible
um so I do have two kids I have joint
custody of my daughter but her mom would
be uh to be willing to work with me in
the situation and stuff so okay so
that's one option okay so now we add
let's say you can get an 18 to 20 an
hour job and you're adding 20 hours you
can do the math on that man let me tell
you something that one option alone
would allow you to power through uh the
the 5K car loan the 5K in collections
you could power through that in about
two three months okay just really
crushing it now if you get a better day
job or you're making 20 22 25 an hour uh
with any skills that you have I would
make that move I would make that move
right now and then potentially add the
part-time job so that's how that's the
that's the short answer and it's
literally you putting yourself out there
and we are in a wonderful job economy
right now and this is you just shaking
the tree here to go okay what's
available out there where I where I live
where I can make 20 25 bucks an hour
even if it's just sheer labor right now
you're driving a truck and delivering
parts so there's no question in my mind
that you can go do this but you got to
look intently and then decide and
understand this this doesn't have to be
a major career move this is a season by
which you are bringing in more money I
love that you called to ask how can I
make my shovel bigger and that's just
Ramsey solution speak for more income so
I can pay off the debt faster but those
are your three options
right
um so I think that I can do all that I
guess one other question I did have was
where do I start because I know you guys
say don't worry about the interest rates
and everything but I'm kind of I know
the baby steps and how to get there and
everything but I don't know do I start
with the collections do I start on the
student loans do I go on the cars you
know I I guess I'm just like I got my
hands in every which direction and I'm
like I need to focus yeah what kind of
debts in the collections
uh there's a few medical bills uh there
was a Zales card
um
and do you have any savings Thomas you
have any cash
100 bucks on me and that and that's the
thing too is I don't have stuff it
wasn't stuff that I accumulated so I
don't really have anything to sell right
right no I hear you
um the first move I would make is I
would call
um the debt that you have in collections
and just kind of let them know hey
here's the situation I have a hundred
bucks to my name uh I'm gonna be adding
some part-time jobs to get this out or
to be paying this off but what can I
settle with you guys because sometimes
they'll go I mean even Pennies on the
dollar at times I mean so I would go and
ask and just tell them your situation
and be like you're not gonna be getting
anything anytime soon
um but can we settle this and if they
agree and you guys go back and forth
don't ever give them access to your bank
account don't tell them where you work
don't do any of that but if they will
settle get it in writing and use that
but I would but I would start with the
collections of that being behind so I
would start with that first and foremost
then knock out that person alone
and then the car and then the student
loan how much uh you have five left on
your car how much how much is it worth
just
for the heck I don't know how much it's
a word I will tell you it's a 2011 Camry
okay it's got about two hundred and
something thousand dollars on it and I
know the yeah Market from just hearing
you guys that said this went up but I
don't believe that car is worth a lot so
no you're fine you're fine I just
thought like for the heck of it what if
you could get
you know I didn't know what kind of car
it was what if you could get 20 grand
for it or something I'm like you could
use that to knock out some of this debt
I'd be wanting to sell it if I didn't
know right no and it would work for that
so yeah so Thomas this is going to just
be a level of diligence and a level of
intensity that you probably haven't felt
because a lot of this is so normal right
you got some some car loans some
personal loans you got some stuff in
collections you know I mean like this
what you described is so normal and so
for you you're gonna have to shift out
of that mindset and I know you're ready
because you called and we're asking
um but you're gonna feel that intensity
for not forever and not for long because
23 000 you could really knock this out I
want you to up your income because
you're making about 35 a year so I think
you can make a whole lot more a whole
lot
um and I think that's going to be your
best bet
right and that's my thing too is uh
Ken I kind of wanted to ask you so I
wanted to eventually obviously not now
because I know you guys talk about cash
flow and your degrees eventually I'd
want to go back and cash flow to get my
degree as a mental health counselor but
I'm not sure
I know the concept of how I had to do it
obviously you've had a pocket
but uh so for example There's jobs here
where I'm at there's two jobs one you
can do like a behavioral Tech and then
there was another one was a driver job
and you talk about part-time well the
driver job was like 11 to 25 an hour I'm
assuming it's based off your experience
or whatever but that kind of gets your
foot in the door and it's a part-time
job would that be something to look into
yeah but I want you to look at
everything because let me just give you
some anecdotal uh evidence here Walmart
had a major announcement
that it was last year but they they are
paying tuition
they are reimbursing tuition paying
tuition
so if I'm you in the situation you're in
I'm going hey am I willing to work at
Walmart I mean I'm driving and
delivering electrical parts right now
there's no shame in your game there but
if I can work at Walmart making 20 25 an
hour
and they're going to help me with my
with my degree later on I'm going to
work at Walmart right now that takes
care of a couple things number one I've
increased my income I go get a part-time
job on top of that I'm working every
time I don't have my little baby girl uh
with me or and you're working hard man
and so then I once I get all the debt
paid off I can pull back and I'm a
full-time Walmart employee I try to move
up within the organization and I work
with him long enough to where I get an
opportunity and I can they'll pay my way
through school and then I make the
transition there are so many companies
that are willing to pay tuition I would
at least start there and look at it
especially the kind of work you're doing
now
right yeah I will definitely look into
it I will say I did look in the warmer
and I have worked for Walmart in the
past I've worked there for about three
and a half years when I was in school
um so I'm sure they would take me back
um I will I will say one more thing and
I'll let you guys go I don't want to
hold Jeff uh Rachel
um as far as this
so I know this is bad to say but I
haven't really started baby step one
I've just been doing baby step two
because I don't have anything to sell so
my question is
how do I get that thousand do I just
take you know percentages of my check
each time I put it back to do that like
yeah how would I do that yeah I would do
that and when you're doing this
part-time job you're gonna just put
everything extra you're making to
fulfill that thousand dollars first and
foremost but hey stay on the line Thomas
Austin's gonna pick up I'm gonna give
you 12 months of Financial Peace
University because it's gonna have every
dollar plus with it which is our
budgeting tool and these two things
together really I think are going to
propel you for but I'm excited for you
Thomas I mean you re I I feel like man
you have such hope that you can change
this around you're asking the right
questions and this is possible it's
going to feel uncomfortable at first but
man in 24 months your life's gonna look
a whole lot different thanks for calling
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
James 1 19-20 my dear brothers and
sisters take note of this everyone
should be quick to listen slow to speak
and slow to become angry because human
anger does not produce the righteousness
that God desires
Fred Rogers Mr Rogers oh I love me so Mr
Rogers no in times of stress the best
thing we can do for each other is to
listen with our ears and our hearts and
be assured that our questions are just
as important as our answers
brilliant hey good question asking with
people
when people are having a hard time or
they're sharing something when you just
ask questions yeah it goes a long way
just keep asking yeah by the way
world-class coaches I've learned from
them I've sat with some professional
like we're talking about Pro uh you know
executive coaches they ask what
questions just keep asking what you
really want to just connect with
somebody you don't know what to say keep
asking what questions well what what
what's pretty good by the way one other
thing on Mr Rogers before we move on he
could read from a phone book and you
would go that's amazing
that's that's brilliant he could read an
ad for a dry cleaner and he'd go wow
you should start like changing into a
cardigan and changing your shoes before
they're answering it like you did like
Mr Roger like Vibes let me just tell you
something if if Dave would allow we
could put a closet right here behind me
and and I would come in right here this
would be great it'd be on date which
shows when Dave isn't here because he
would like clothesline me if I tried to
do it but I would come in open it up do
the whole little thing show your shoe
what's your shoe game mine's just some
black today I got the Air Force Ones
high top folks this is I'm pretty drippy
today as the kids would say is that a
kid thing I I hope it is now I'm
terrified I think it is yeah the out the
fit here's how they say it the fit is
drippy
[Music]
you enjoy your teenage boys you and
George teach me these yeah I don't but I
would do it I would like to take off
today's shacket I would walk in hang up
the shack it and put on a cardigan and
change my shoes I think it would be fine
turn into Mr Rogers oh there it is there
it is all right Michael is up next
please Michael is up in New Mexico hey
Michael welcome to the show
hey there Superfly Cannon Rachel it's an
honor to speak with y'all you're welcome
thank you I am super here thank you yes
how can we help I uh
I have a question in regards to the
vehicles and things of motors and wheels
I I have quite a few things with motors
and wheels to the tune of about a
hundred and seventy thousand dollars and
I'm wondering if my situation could
possibly be an exception to the rule of
not having things with motors and wheels
equal more than half of your annual
income
all right so what's the situation that's
quite a setup what makes you the
exception
uh well uh several several of these well
there's vehicles and well there's three
trucks two cars a race car an enclosed
race trailer two camper trailers a boat
and uh a horse trailer and a few of
those are appreciating in value
um I have two two of the three trucks
are are old trucks uh like collectors
like a collection collector yeah and are
these all paid for
yes oh so you own all these outright
yes sir and so the value of all of these
things together your your work day yeah
that's a different application because
you you you've paid cash for these
things you don't have a car payment you
don't have you're not overextended
either is my guess I'm I'm guessing that
is that correct
I I believe so yes sir what do you mean
you believe so like what's your what's
your financial net worth do you have any
debt at all
um zero debt
um and a net worth of right around 2
million oh Michael you're good I knew it
Michael you're awesome man how much do
you make a year
um my base pays only about 120 but it
ranges from maybe 180 to 350 depending
on where in the world I'm working yeah
yeah you're fine because of your
financial situation but but it brings up
a very good well yeah and the reason
that the rule is there is because
anything with wheels majority of the
time goes down in value right unless
it's a classic vehicle appreciating Yes
except for very small exceptions yes and
so yeah we don't want people out there
that has
you know a hundred thousand dollar car
and they're making thirty thousand
dollars a year or something and so
that's kind of where that rule of thumb
comes from
um but your net worth yeah and it's and
it's
um yeah and I think the rule of thumb
too can apply to that to your net worth
as well just making sure that you have
that yeah and what Rachel's saying
Michael is is important it's a general
rule of thumb we're we're Dave's trying
to help people see hey you don't want to
be outsized in the money you're spending
that did you put towards a cash car
based on your income because we're
telling you to pay cash so we want you
to pay a higher proportion of your
income than you should in your situation
number one you make really good income
number two all you own all these things
out right cash and and my goodness your
net worth is fantastic so man you're
great I gotta ask what are the club what
are the older trucks are they classics
uh one of them's a 85 K10 pickup truck
it was one of our Old Ranch trucks that
I restored oh that's awesome another one
is a 77 F250 that was given to me as my
first vehicle and that's all Rachel has
no appreciation she loves cars I love
classic cars I point out I like classic
cars I don't like newfangled cars I like
the the old ones I'm a child of the 80s
that 85 F10
what a beaut it's fantastic it's such a
great truck I gotta tell you yeah man
you're good you're in great shape thanks
for the call I appreciate it enjoy I
take that I take that 85 truck off of
him today I promise you that's a slick
vehicle so funny you're like Mr Rogers
old man Vibes I'm getting all of this
last time Mr Rogers would never drive an
85. he'd drive a gremlin
I don't even know what that is not a
movie I feel see this is why we need to
be on the show together these
generational gaps there are a lot of
people don't even know what a gremlin is
well you what year were you born let's
get people perspective what year were
you born I was born in 74. that's a
massive Gap that's a massive Gap Ken if
you were born in the 40s that would be a
massive Gap just as far as like cultural
changes I think it's a pretty big gap
maybe not massive a gremlin was a was a
movie The Gremlins right oh geez can we
guys can you help me out can somebody
pull up a gremlin and show all the young
people Rachel's age and younger what a
gremlin is it's the ugliest car ever
made why would you put Mr Rogers in that
because I just think that's what he
drives you'll see he would drive an
Oldsmobile like what do you see the
gremlin I could see him rolling up to
the old Studio the PBS studio in a
gremlin oh maybe a station wagon all
right it's gone they can't get it the
wood paneled station wagon that's that's
a child of the 80s that was I think I
confused and they're pulling up Gremlins
in the movie see see even the guys in
the booth got confused and pulled up
little creatures from the movie I know
it's an actual car oh no no it's a car
oh geez I gotta do everything myself
all right you guys you may be hating
this show but if you love it consider
subscribing leave a review
it just happened that's fantastic
conversation because you're talking
about Gremlins and that's a car it's a
movie
oh look there's Jay Leno okay jaleno's
cool here it is Jay's garage and Jay's
got a gremlin
oh okay I've seen those Ken yeah okay I
got you that's a grandma okay okay okay
okay
what year they stop making that yeah I
don't know I gotta look at me oh you
know what I am excited about you know
what I'm excited about holding in my
hands right here what is it very
exciting details about our smart
conference you know coven knocked it
offline like it did a lot of events and
this is a full day event all of the
Ramsay personalities including Rachel
myself Dave John deloney
um and George Campbell uh it's gonna be
unbelievable we cover the full spectrum
obviously money your mental and
emotional health your work uh marriage
uh we're gonna have special guest Craig
groeschel uh and his wife gonna speak it
on marriage uh it's a great day and it's
Saturday October 22nd Dallas Texas so
we're back Dallas Texas Saturday October
22nd the smart conference we've got
incredible deals for you you can reserve
your seats today
ramseysolutions.com
events that's ramseysolutions.com
events and there's a special Vibe and
energy when you get six thousand plus
people in one room dedicated to just
learning and growing and I'd love to see
you there join us ramseysolutions.com
events yeah make sure to check that out
you guys uh Ken great show today enjoyed
hosting with you and thanks to James Ben
Zach Andrew Austin everyone in the back
and thank you America for listening
we'll be back
thank you
foreign
[Music]
co-host on the Ramsay show if you want
to do your debt free scream live on the
show visit ramseysolutions.com set free
screen we'd love for you to come to
Nashville and tell Dave your story
that's ramsesolutions.com debt free
screen
[Music]